vote for me we all get to the promised  land because we're not going to get  there by one I want all of us to get  together because that's what we are  we're God's people and we're going to  get there together we're going to work  this thing out together you guys  following this do it because in the  Bible I read it sent a house the body  cannot stand I don't know what Bible  Senator Warner is reading but it's not  the Bible I've been reading because he  don't seem to be doing the right thing  by him that must be Central we're not  doing this right here trying to cancel  me out but he can't cancel me out cause  I've been mad of God God loved me and I  can tell you that right now he loves me  and I'ma tell you this right here cause  it getting cold outside but cold weather  only make us better yeah uh really just  commenting on everything from uh police  responses to Godliness and and weather  and just everything